[Musique]
bonsoir quand il sera grand
on dit que les pneus des autos bon et
bien et toucheront plus les routes
est ce que tu es quoi non je n'y crois
pas je crois pas qu'en iran en amérique
en une demi-heure
est-ce que tu y crois donc que les
petits enfants iront passer des vacances
sur la lune est ce que tu es croit en
tout cas tous que les chevaux parlerons
je n'y crois pas
enfin peut-être
non non je ne sais pas mais moi françois
oui à quoi ça sert de télévision
apprendre des choses
seulement remière chaussée à prendre mes
choix mentionnons des fois on prend des
choses c'est pas comme l'école quand
même pas une école mais les formes
celikkol à la télévision mais quand on
ne fait pas l'école quand sur les
histoires quand vous raconte l'histoire
alors là c'est pas pareil je crois qu'on
qu'on apprend lui bien sûr qu'on
m'apprend les cités on apprend les
dessins l'apprend la pâte à modeler et
puis écuyers
et pas faire des tâches web ou en soule
qu'est la télévision un alors là c'est
aussi parce qu'on apprend
merlin on apprend et l'histoire crise
toujours n'ont pas toujours les joueurs
prennent presque toujours nous pas
presque toujours c'est des fois c'est
bien rigolade
oui des fois il faut pleurer quand
maîtrise et qu'on me contente pas la
même chose est sûre le but cinéma si ça
n'existait plus
je reviens une idée comme ça sur le
moment
chose que je ferai
je peux pas imaginer que ça ne te plus
je peux pas annuler les choses
c'est vrai quand on vous pose des
questions quand vous dit si vous étiez
sur une île déserte si vous deviez
séjourné avec telle ou telle personne
il faut une raison de vie ou de mort
vous deviez vous le débarrasser de tel
ou tel ou bien que vous bien qu'on
porteriez vous ça je peux pas imaginer
des choses qu'on ne peut plus dans les
cafés si je peux aller partout dans
paris vous balader je vous assure
parce que j'ai pas envie de me cacher à
partir du moment je n'ai pas envie de me
cacher chez comme tout le monde entier
du moment je suis comme tout le monde
les gens peuvent penser à une vague
ressemblance et les gens qui me
ressemblent pas envie de me déranger
parce qu'ils me reconnaissent n'ont pas
envie de me déranger je peux faire ce
que je veux je vais partout vous avez
une faculté de paraître jeune gourou
absolument mais je voulais dire vous
êtes jeanne moreau et que ça n'a pas
d'importance et n'a pas d'importance je
peux pas j'ai pas un physique
retentissant pour les gens me voient
sans voix et quelquefois ils me voient
mais ça n'a pas d'importance aux 10 et
j'avais les infections ou
accidentellement
vous n'allez pas voir le film rarement
on ne voyait pas d'erreur qu'est ce que
vous faites
je suis sur l'écran je vous fait pour me
voir me pour lire des articles qui sont
destinés aux lecteurs rien au mexique
ils vont aller vers eux excepté vous
fait mais on n'est personne un contrôle
de vous même sur vous même maintenant
puisque je suis entouré de gens qui
contrôlent qui me regardent et qui vous
disent eh bien c'est mal oui j'aime
avoir des maîtres je vois mal face on
compatit métriques
mieux ça va c'est oui oui la sortie de
l'oeil que je vois un petit miroir dis
moi c'est vraiment la plus laide mais
c'était ça venait comme ça de jeux
d'enfants qu'elles soient timide et très
complexée qu'elle ne se connaissent pas
du tout ne sachant pas comment
s'habiller qu'elle sache jamais comment
se tenir
elle ne sait pas quoi faire de ses bras
tout ça c'est vrai mais elle est
tellement comédienne elle aime tellement
joué et finalement elle va passer par
dessus sa timidité par dessus ses
compères payer une chose qui peut être
belle c'est qu'elles soient d'ordre et
déjeuné ou dîné avec elle se régale
c'est un festival de vacheries gentille
qu'elle se lance comme ça mais c'est un
jeu entre elles depuis sûrement de
l'enfance laquelle est la doublure de
l'ofs
ma soeur à sa porte et ils sont de plus
en plus qu'est-ce qui se passe
ne restent pas que moi je me risque va
t'arriver oh bah ouais voilà en france
après avoir roulé dit que lens alors
finalement lèvres elle apprend aussi
pour embrasser commandement et il ya je
vous dis
je suis très prudente pour traverser les
rues
ça
je pense à l'accident avant qu'il puisse
arriver je pense à l'accident avant
qu'il puisse arriver
et que ma vie s'arrête là et que ma vie
s'arrête là le chômage la maladie
[Musique]
mais rigueur
la mort jamais la mort jamais lui est
très forts pour ça c'est qu'ils arrivent
à faire sortir des trucs de n'importe
qui et donc votre avis à moi je suis
tout à fait ravi je suis assez fatigué
mais je suis ravi il faut lui faire
confiance totalement puisque justement
on n'a pas l'occasion de travailler sur
un scénario composé conventionnelle etc
c'est une question de confiance où on
est d'accord avec ce que fait godard
voulait pas d'accord et dans ce cas là
on tourne pas avec lui je dire si on est
d'accord comme moi je le suis a priori
on accepte tout et on accepte quand je
dis tout s'est vraiment tous les gars
comme moi j'ai fait des choses dans file
dans ce film que je n'aurais jamais
imaginé faire autrement dit souvent
c'est de godard lui même alors comme
personnage beaucoup je trouve que c'est
un être très très intelligent très
tendre et très timide évidemment
très intéressant d'un patin godard et
misogynes que vous en pensez un bon
conseil
allez demander à monsieur jean luc
godard lui même il vous dira très
précisément ce qu'ils pensent des femmes
moi je pense rien je prends le train
parce qu'une femme c'est bien plus
intéressant que qu'un garçon on peut on
peut se permettre n'importe quoi avec
une femme pourquoi marine à vue pour
avoir un objet inconnu c'est que si
j'avais un objet connu parce que tu
l'amdh ans et au dessus qui sont pour la
plupart desquelles tout à fait différent
détient n'ont pas beaucoup
voilà bien mais c'est bon tu penses que
marina enfin car vous allez bientôt la
fois un peu
molle et dure
[Rires]
[Musique]
jégo et baby mama
oui moi aussi j'étais là pourquoi
toujours derrière moi parce que je pense
toujours à toi
savard est à lui alors à m ainsi andré
voulait plus bac j'ai couru pas si pas
d'ardeur ne sera pas puisqu'elle joue
bien je le fais exprès alors j'écris par
ci par là
oui moi aussi je fais là pourquoi
toujours derrière nous
parce que je pense toujours à toi
à détrôner du cri'art doha mais
des trombes d'eau
on s'est trop mer
rien n'est perdu nous sommes perdus on
va on s'est trouvé d'autre part là j'ai
chanté trop vous tutoient faut que tu
fasses ado je peux pas attendre ta peau
la caisse claire parce que tu es dans
les trucs quand tu t'appelles comment
faire ce que j'ai pas du tout de retour
j'entends et jack images en temps parce
qu'elle chante appartement pendant ce
que je dise demain par une
je crois que ça va se terminer en duo
des non c'est mauvais
rien n'est perdu nous sommes on va le
trouver
[Musique]